i hit my head that was your idea
that was actually yours how long did we
plan that that's the whole
movie right there that's it that's what
we were trying to do
hi i'm bob odenkirk hi i'm daniel
bernhardt
we're going to break down a scene from
our new movie nobody
[Music]
what are you still doing here old man
my character has been on a quest on this
night where he's trying to get
revenge for a home break-in and he does
actually track down
the people who broke into his house
but he sort of immediately feels bad
for them so he is frustrated and angry
and he gets on this bus
to go home thinking that he's just going
to have to live with this
with this failure and loss and and anger
and then these jerks get on the bus
they're kind of intimidating everybody
and then my character realizes oh god
sent these guys for me to beat them
out of that ignites the whole rest of
the movie
what he does here oh yeah so he acts out
on his violence
he finds reward in that but in the end
it's um actually causes him more
trouble than uh it's not just this
satisfying
uh residue he he's left with a bad
situation
because of what he does here my
character
i'm gonna [ __ ] you up
boom i get hit first right
i get hit first then
i come back
i get hit in the gut i get hit again i
ain't getting hit again i hit my head
that was your idea that was actually
yours how long did we plan that
that's the whole [ __ ] movie right
there
that's it that's what we were trying to
do we talked about that for
two years and that was what you wanted
to get punched
and hit my head on like a bar or
something
and i'm really glad because it's so
pathetic
right it's like you never see jason
statham
do that you never see jason bourne
hit his [ __ ] head you never see
uh liam neeson do that but that's your
comedy and that was so
fun and that was one i swear to god that
was one of the first things he said dan
it'll be so much fun
when i get hit i whack my head and so
it's like
to me this thing starts with this
bravado swagger line
i'm gonna [ __ ] you up and then right
away he gets hit
he barely gets a punch in he gets hit he
gets hit he hits his head
kirk and i were fight coordinators so we
put the fight together we choreographed
the fights of course
with our stunt coordinator greg greg
ramento who's also the second under
director who actually shot the fight
but we all worked very very tightly
together
with bob because it was very important
to us that bob approved everything that
he was comfortable with what he was
doing also that we had a story
which was actually very very important
to bob you want to tell a story
you don't want to just hit smack there
has to be a story in it
that's the most important thing so i'm
going from out of practice
getting hit getting hurt sloppy
to barely putting it together uh
and some real good clumsy moves just
throwing
kirk into the wall here and what was
funny is you know after i did this like
three times
you might remember kirk said to me throw
me harder
and i was like harder right you sure
yeah throw me as hard as you can throw
me
when i started to train bob we realized
right away that he was
very very talented with choreography
that he actually picked up things very
fast
we break down fighting sections so we
have section one two
up to ten whatever and i would tell bob
bob i need the beginning of section
three he would know it
the beginning of section five he would
know it so because bob was so prepared
when we actually shot the fight david
leach and gregory mentor
decided to do as little cuts as possible
so the first shot when you watch it it's
actually all on bob
we're pulling back and i think you did
probably like something like 10 moves
without a cut
and that is very very very rare because
usually you
cut you have to cut because you got to
hide something but
bob did all of his own fights and we
stayed on him as long as we could till
we actually had to cut because of an
impact
and that's a huge compliment to him you
just don't see that so much anymore part
of it is that
relatively new style of very cutty bass
yeah like paul greengrass style
which uh started with the bourne films
and certainly
the taken films do do it for other
reasons
you know we wanted to go back to an
older style in every way in every way
in the kind of character it was the kind
of darkness of the script and the story
and the character
and the film style so ilya nyshill are
directed
gregor mentor directed the action
sequences and everybody worked together
to
to choose the the style and the tone and
this was just a great
joy to shoot
it's actually hard to shoot in a
confined space daniel do you want to
talk about no um
yeah it was a little bit of a challenge
but um
you know we rehearsed this fight for
months
so we were really really prepared so
when we rehearsed it we
we actually set ourselves a little stage
that looked like the bus
and to be honest to me it wasn't such a
big challenge because we knew exactly
what we were doing
and we knew that we had an incredible
talent and bob was prepared
the biggest thing for us was really
having bob ready
that was the most important thing
because one of the decisions we made we
didn't want to double
we don't want to do the typical thing
where you go behind the actor and you
show
a stun double doing it and we didn't
want to do that so like i said earlier
we really wanted to stay this whole
fight is on bob
there's barely reactions on us just when
you really really needed it but it's
all favoring bob you know a lot of
movies
and tv shows when you shoot a confined
space you rebuild it but you kind of
build it about it two feet
wider and two feet longer so you give
yourself that room for the camera
but this is a real bus so we were not
able to do
any alterations outside of taking seats
out
right right um so it was really uh
tribute to
daniel and the crew of stunt actors
and the camera people
who were able to work within this
confined area
and create this uh intense moment i also
think
the co confines makes it more intense
and scary
intimate scary dangerous and what we did
we did a lot of pulling
just like this and like that because of
the space yeah it was all designed for
that
the bus fight scene in nobody is kind of
a huge deal
to us a core aspect of this
whole effort was that i wanted to make a
not ironic
action movie and i wanted to do my own
fighting and i wanted you to see that i
was doing it
and i wanted it to be good and i wanted
the character to get
hurt and i wanted him to struggle
in the course of fighting because those
are things we haven't really seen a lot
of from action stars of the last few
years
you could almost feel like they're a
robot that fights and doesn't feel
anything
so i wanted my character to be more far
more human
right from the get-go and in fact
when i say the line i'm gonna [ __ ] you
up to these guys
i sort of hope that you can see in the
character's face that he's not sure
if he's gonna actually do that or if
it's just a
goal it's just his uh
intention he's putting out into the
universe so
we wanted to show this slightly
different spin on a
on a action hero somebody who's more
human
and somebody who screws up and i think
hopefully somebody who
doubts himself and who you doubt who you
the audience
go i don't think he's gonna win this
fight that that's not something you
feel in most action films and if we
could get you to
even subconsciously think this guy
he's not really up to it then that would
be a great
great achievement when you left
abandoning a certain debt that needs
repayment and your creditor
is aware of your resurrection
[Music]
thanks for watching us break down that
cool scene
from our super cool amazing awesome
kick-ass movie
nobody it's amazing trust me
[Music]
you